today on the Matt Walsh show you know
the goal posts have shifted in a massive
way originally we were told that we were
locking down to flatten the curve right
that's what the the phrase was now it
seems they want us to stay inside until
you know nobody is dying from Kovan 19
anymore which means we could be locked
inside forever so we'll talk about that
also five headlines including The Price
is Right raising money for baby butchers
and in our daily cancellation we will
cancel a New York Times writer who
thinks that the sport of running somehow
discriminates against black people yes
that is the claim and we will address
that all of that on the way but starting
with this a recent CNN Headline claims
that 68% of Americans say a vaccine is
needed before returning to normal life
that was as the direct quote from the
CNN headline which I think has since
been taken down because it is as
expected basically fake news the actual
data shows that 68% of Americans believe
a vaccine is quote very important it's a
very important factor when they quote
think about their willingness to return
to normal activities so that's what
that's what the the survey said from
Gallup and the way that CNN interpreted
it and spread it around is that 60% of
Americans say a vaccine is needed before
they'll go back to their normal life
There is obviously a clear and
significant difference between very
important factor and needed okay those
are two different things
even so it's it's troubling it's
troubling because it does show that many
Americans seem to be at least hoping
that maybe they can wait until there's a
vaccine before they get back to living
their lives and even more so it shows us
what the media wants us to think we
think okay so what we can take from this
headline is is is not that nearly 70
percent of Americans think a vaccine is
absolutely necessary but that CNN thinks
we should think that a vaccine is
absolutely necessary before we get back
to our normal lives so you notice the
massive shift that has occurred and not
just in polls or in see
headlines we were originally told that
we need to shut down for about two weeks
15 days to slow the spread was the
slogan but the interesting thing about
15 days to slow the spread is the part
where it says 15 days and also to slow
the spread okay it is well past 15 days
now it's well past 30 days now it's
where we're you know what it's past 45
days I mean we we are going on multiples
of 15 and also the spread has been
slowed flatten the curve was the other
motto and we've done that too the only
places in America that haven't flattened
the curve are the places where there was
never a curve to flatten which is the
case in many states by the way yet much
of the country is still locked down and
the states that open are still condemned
as as being havens of ignorant reckless
redneck grandma killers so what happened
what what happened well the goal posts
have moved not just moved
they've been uprooted and placed in an
entirely different stadium somewhere
across the town and nobody knows where
because now we're hearing that the curve
must be this this is according to a
Times article the way they put it they
said we have to we have to squash the
curve not flatten it squash it
California is now going to remain closed
until and this is what the governor of
California says Newsom until there are
zero Kovan 19 deaths for two weeks zero
for two weeks
doctor foul she was testifying in front
of a Senate hearing yesterday and he
said that he was we should be wary of
opening schools because children might
not be quote completely immune to the
effects of the virus so we've gone from
flatten the curve slow the spread to
complete immunity is is what we should
be looking for it if we don't have that
that we need to be you know careful
about opening things up we're also told
by the media and public health officials
that reopening cannot begin until we
have mass testing testing and tracing is
the buzz buzz phrase over all the
objective has shifted from flatten the
curve and slow the spread both goals
accomplished
to a vaguer idea of remaining locked
away until we have some kind of
guarantee of safety or immunity now I
think a few notes of sanity are needed
here a few notes of sanity should be
interjected into all of this madness
number one and let's just be very clear
about this we cannot wait for a vaccine
can't do it there may never be one first
of all there's there's no guarantee that
there will be vaccine I'm not a medical
expert myself I I can't tell you that
I'm an expert in how vaccines work but I
do know this there are a lot of diseases
and viruses out there for which there is
no vaccine so you never have any
guarantee on that even if there is a
vaccine it could be years away okay we
cannot wait that long our society will
be in ruins if we try to keep it shut
down for that long and the number of
dead from homelessness starvation
suicide drug overdoses etc will far far
exceed even the most dire and also false
coronavirus death predictions besides
people are not going to comply many
people are already not complying the
idea that we should much less that we
can keep hundreds of millions of
Americans under mass house arrest for
years is simply madness and the fact
that I have to explain this that anyone
has to explain it is madness so the
Americans out there whatever percentage
they might represent and I don't know
what that percentage is it should be
zero so if it's anything about zero
that's a problem the percentage of
Americans who are dreaming of a day when
they can emerge from their homes under
the protection of a vaccine might as
well push that thought from their minds
if you're in that group you just forget
about it it ain't gonna happen you are
going to have to get back to your life
before then get used to it you're gonna
have to get back to your life when the
disease is out there and there is no
vaccine for it get used to it it's gonna
happen or else
you're not gonna have much of a life to
get back to second point of of sanity in
fact before we get to that point I want
to tell you about our friends over at
wise foods you know having enough food
to last you in the event of a real
emergency is well it's it's like
insurance policy so we all know that
it's important to have health insurance
and car insurance
well what about food insurance what
about having an insurance that you that
you're gonna have all the basic food
necessities that you need and when
government resources are strained it can
be days if not weeks before fresh fruit
is available don't put yourself in a
situation when you need food during an
emergency but you don't have it prepare
for that today
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you can order online and
have nutritious meals shipped directly
to your doorstep when preparing their
meals all you need is four cups of water
and the water doesn't even need to be
hot okay you simply pour the food into
the water you stir and cover after about
15 minutes the meal is ready some meals
could even be prepared directly in the
pouch so it's as easy as that ready wise
uses the finest ingredients in latest
food preparation technology to ensure
optimal taste and freshness so it's not
just that you're prepared you're also
not sacrificing just good taste while
you're doing it it's it's our
responsibility to be prepared for
emergencies and that's something that
we're all you know learning now so this
week my listeners get free shipping at
ready wise calm when entering Walsh at
checkout or by calling eight five five
four seven five three zero eight nine
ready wise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today that's
ready wise re ad Y Wis EECOM from a code
Walsh to get free shipping today okay
second point the first point is that we
can't wait for a vaccine just can't do
it
second point testing and tracing is not
the Holy Grail that it's being made out
to be it is not realistic to expect
that it will be white that that you know
tests will be widely available to 330
million people anytime soon and even if
they were available so what I mean let's
say that that every person in the
country takes a test tomorrow great what
about next week what about the week
after next month if a negative test is
supposed to grant me permission to go
about my day and participate in society
how long does that petition her
permission last I mean are we gonna have
to take tests every single day wouldn't
that require hundreds of billions of
tests to be available not to mention the
capacity to distribute and process all
of those tests now I'm not saying that
tests are unimportant or that we
shouldn't have them or anything like
that but there's a certain sort of
fantastical ambiguity about the testing
rhetoric that troubles me with people
acting like that well this is the here
we go here's the magical switch that we
can flip and if we could just get that
the tests going and in wide testing well
then we could get back to our lives it
sort of seems that our elected officials
really do want daily tests for everyone
forever but who knows if that's what
they want because all we've ever gotten
from these people from elected officials
is sort of scenes we don't know exactly
what they have in mind or what they
think we need in order to get back to
our lives because there's been almost no
clarity from anyone from the top down to
include President Trump despite the fact
especially him when you look you look at
President Trump in the way he seems to
feel about the lockdowns on Twitter is
very different from President Trump
anywhere else you got Twitter Trump and
then Trump at a press conference or
trumpet real-life Twitter Trump has been
against lockdowns this whole time press
conference Trump is all on board flip I
mean Twitter Trump wish was was shouting
on Twitter all caps weeks ago liberate
liberate the states we have to liberate
them and then press conference Trump the
next day said that he disagreed with
Georgia opening up
okay so there's been
just almost no clarity from anyone and
not just no clarity but cut
contradicting themselves on a day-to-day
basis but we're supposed to continue
sitting around twiddling our thumbs
putting everything on hold in our whole
lives until we're told otherwise until
they figure out what the hell they're
doing it cannot continue this way third
point this is very important there will
always be coronavirus deaths probably
even with a vaccine and this stands to
reason because there are always flu
deaths and quite a lot of them in fact
even with a vaccine yeah the tens of
thousands of people might die from this
virus every year forever that might well
be the case we have to learn to live
with that reality just as we live with
the reality of so many other diseases
not to mention all the other fatal
calamities that threaten us every single
day of our lives every single day you
wake up and walk out of your house even
if you don't walk out of your house no
matter what you do there are a million
things that could kill you some of them
more likely than others and the really
scary thing is it is a certainty that
one of those things will eventually kill
you you will die of all the potential
things that could kill you one day and
it could be today it could be tomorrow
it could be before I'm done saying this
sentence one of those things will kill
you you will die not just you everyone
you know is gonna die everyone you've
ever known they're all gonna die the
earth itself is gonna die okay now again
I mean these are
that should need to be made but I think
they do because the way some people are
talking about this virus and the way
they're approaching it it's as if they
think that if we can just hide away
sacrifice whatever we need to sacrifice
even if it's the entire economy 30
million jobs whatever we will get to a
point where we're safe where we're
completely safe and then we can go about
our lives like we're immortal or
something no maybe that's just that's
just not the case and that doesn't mean
you know the reality that we're mortal
we're all gonna die of something that
doesn't mean that we should be suicidal
it doesn't mean that we should be
nihilistic it doesn't mean that we
should take a position of not caring
about our lives or not trying to protect
our lives it allows our loved ones of
our loved ones quite the opposite I
think it's all the more reason to live
our lives with joy and vigor and courage
because we're only going to be here for
a short time
you know we may be able to momentarily
extend our stay on earth by hiding under
our beds indefinitely but then what kind
of life would that even be eventually we
have to confront the risks we have to
accept them we have to take whatever
reasonable precautions were comfortable
with and get back to living that's
that's the only choice we have and we
just have to accept that and it seems
like we are not willing to accept that
reality all right I want to tell you
about LifeLock
you know internet scams happen and
sometimes the internet scams I mean
there are the really obvious ones that
you know about I mean hopefully you
could see coming a mile away like the
Nigerian prince or whatever you know you
inherited 30 million dollars from some
relative in Africa you know hopefully we
all know that that's fake all those
people still fall for it apparently but
the scams are you know they're getting
more sophisticated and they're Burnet I
there's been a time or two when I've
almost clicked on something not because
I thought I won 30 million but just
something else it was a very clever
little scam
and I almost clicked and I stopped
myself but I was very close to you know
who knows what would happen next in a
recent study research has revealed a
substantial rise in the number of cyber
attacks performed by websites posing as
for example Netflix and that's kind of
nuts because scammers are focusing more
attention on people streaming content
during this stay at home era nobody ever
accused these criminals of being dumb
and hackers are shifting their resources
away from targeting businesses and
towards activities that can reach us
directly in our homes on average over
2,600 coronavirus related cyber attacks
occur each day so every day we put our
information at risk on the internet and
cyber criminals keep finding new ways to
steal identities that's why we have
LifeLock LifeLock as a leader in
identity theft protection
LifeLock detects a wide range of
identity threat threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
look no one can ever prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses life lock
can see threats that you might miss
though on your own if you're just
monitoring your credit and trying to do
this on your own join now and save up to
25% off your first year go to life lock
calm slash Walsh that's life lock calm
slash Walsh for 25% off ok let's go to
your headlines number one if you were a
price of prices right fan and I've
always been more of a jeopardy and weal
fortune purse myself but if you are
price of prices right fan you may want
to reconsider ever watching the show
again and I'm not much I'm not one for
boycotts normally but I think donating
money a company donating money to mass
murderers is about as good a reason to
boycott as you're ever going to find The
Price is Right
this past Monday aired a primetime
special called The Price is Right at
night Andrew Paul the drag queen was was
there for some reason raising money for
Planned Parenthood
apparently the show pledged to match all
cumulative prize winnings for the entire
episode and then donate all that to
Planned Parenthood Planned Parenthood is
an organization or a binder that kills
300,000 children every single year more
than 300,000 children every year and we
should also note that Planned Parenthood
already rakes in over a billion dollar
a year okay from from the money they get
from the abortions they may they make
hundreds of millions on abortions and
then also they get five hundred million
dollars a year from the government and
still do because that's something that
our supposed pro-life Republicans never
did anything about when they had the
chance to so not only do they kill
children but if somehow that's not good
enough reason to refrain from making
them the charity that you the Charity
beneficiary for your show they also are
a very rich organization and they're not
hurting for cash at all
there are many organizations out there
that are hurting for cash and that also
don't make a billion dollars a year and
don't make a $509 here from the
government and that also oh yeah don't
kill kids I mean believe it or not there
are organizations out there that need
money that don't get money from the
government and that rather than killing
kids actually like feed kids and clothe
kids and and and and provide services to
kids how about one of those instead
number two here's another massive
massive scandal that will get no
attention whatsoever from the national
media according to a report from the
local ABC affiliate in Harrisburg the
Pennsylvania Health Secretary's mother
was pulled out of a nursing home and put
in a hotel now remember Pennsylvania
sent Kovac patients into nursing homes
just like New York New Jersey California
other states on a mandate they sent
these infected people not people who'd
recovered it in New York it was they had
to be stable so as long as the
coronavirus patient is stable then you
can send them to the nursing home
that doesn't mean recovered and that
doesn't mean not contagious that just
means they're not on their deathbed yet
or anymore and so Pennsylvania did that
to sent the people in nursing homes and
but it
least in the case of the health
secretary's mother she was protected so
shows us the government officials knew
what the result would be knew what would
happen
so they protected their own loved ones
while leaving the rest to die and many
of them did die in fact in Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania has 4,000 Cova deaths 70%
of them and this number keeps going up
because we talked about this I don't
know yesterday a few days ago and the
number wasn't 70% then so now what
they're telling us is that 70% of deaths
in Pennsylvania are from nursing homes
that leaves if you're doing the math
that leaves around a thousand in a state
of 13 million who died outside of
nursing homes which would be point zero
zero eight percent of the population but
the state just extended their lockdowns
into June point zero zero eight percent
of the non nursing home population in
Pennsylvania has died and they extended
the lockdown into June number three this
isn't really a headline but it is news I
want to show you this this is from a vie
Kroy he's a forbes editor and he got
this data from the CDC I want you to
take a look here's a table showing Cova
19 deaths by age group we talked about
the nursing home population well it's
not just nursing homes okay here are how
many died in each group per million
people this is for the United States so
you can see there under 25 your chance
of dying from it is literally one in a
million
okay under 45 it's 17 in a million and
then as you get into the 65 and over and
this this doesn't take into account by
the way pre-existing conditions so if
you're 45 and under generally
your chances of dying or 17 in a million
but if you were but if we're if we were
to narrow that down if you're 45 and
under and healthy then it's it's even
less than 17 in a million but then you
look and as we get into 65 and over then
75 it over especially and and then most
of the vast vast majority of deaths are
85 and over but you look at the bar
graph you compare the bar for 85 and
over to the bar for 45 and under or 25
and under so we shut down our whole
society for a disease that almost
exclusively targets kills people who are
75 and over or 85 and over which is just
incredible
now here's more I want to show you this
too this is also from Roy again CDC
information and it's a map that shows
the percentage of deaths from nursing
homes in each state so take a look and
we've been covering this on the show
extensively but you see there you know
you look around at these states 50
percent 60 percent a lot of 50s and 60
percent 70 percent 80 percent mean this
is truly the nursing home disease we
could rename the coronavirus the nursing
home disease n HD an HD 19 because
that's what it is you take out the
nursing home deaths and the deaths of
people 75 and over so like the the
nursing home set whether they're in
nursing homes or not the nursing home
demographic you take that out and you
have a disease that's about as deadly as
a bad flu and for some demographics a
lot less deadly than a bad flu in a lot
more people who are 24 and under
especially a lot more kids especially
have died of the flu than coded 19
number four the singer Bryan Adams well
in fact before we get to the singer
Bryan Adams because he's in some hot
water for something that he said I want
to tell you about our sponsors the
Benham brothers you know Kobe 19 has had
a huge effect on small business owners
and it's been a devastating for small
business owners which is why it's never
been more important to manage your
business your workforce your workforce
and your workflow really well because
systems are crucial right now the
brothers are great at this these guys
have over a dozen businesses including a
real estate empire that spans over 25 or
I'd rather I should say 35 states I just
demoted them 35 states just a few weeks
ago the Benton brothers launched a new
podcast called expert ownership in their
new podcast which I highly recommend
it's great the band and brothers
interview leaders from all walks of life
to help you navigate your business
through these very challenging times
you'll hear from leaders like Ted Cruz
Al Robertson from duck dynasty many more
and you know this is this is what we
need right now this is the kind of
guidance and leadership that we need go
check out their new podcasts expert
ownership and be sure to subscribe on
Apple podcasts or wherever you listen
we'll drop a link to their podcast in
our show description again that's expert
ownership go check it out now okay
number four the singer Brian Adams got
himself into trouble is caused
controversy because he blamed
coronavirus on quote bat eating bastards
that's what he said an Instagram post
it's been a lot of consternation over
this he says tonight was supposed to be
the beginning of a tenancy of gigs but
thanks to some effing bat eating wet
market animal selling virus making
greedy bastards the whole world is now
on hold not to mention the thousands
have suffered or died from this virus my
message to them other than thanks an
effing lot is go vegan people are very
upset about this I don't see the problem
I mean it seems it seems to be a lot of
accuracy there I mean you know and you
you also have to allow people I know
that this is it's salty language and you
know it's not who cares I think you have
to allow people to be angry okay and the
fact is that this virus did come from
China and it seems pretty obvious that
there was a vibe you know a lab involved
in there somewhere also maybe the wet
markets I mean people are gonna be angry
and you have to allow people to be angry
this is not racism this is just people
are pissed off and yes they're mad at
China they should be and that's okay
we're allowed to
number five a nice segue here perhaps
this perhaps a Bryan Adams post will be
discussed in an upcoming NBC special
reading from deadline it says as Asians
and Asian Americans continue to be the
target of harassment during the
carnivores pandemic NBC Asian America an
arm of NBC News will host a virtual town
hall titled united against hate on May
13th which is what is that thoughts that
you can watch it with guest appearances
from comedian Margaret Cho the town hall
will examine the rise of racism against
asian-americans during the pandemic and
what can be done on a legislative
nonprofit and individual level
that's what NBC News is focused on okay
we got this pandemic thousands dying
economy destroyed what we're focused on
though is is is people saying mean
things about Asians yes that's important
that's the important stuff that's that's
that's the real crisis here right we can
all agree yeah let's go to our daily
cancellation and four days today's daily
cancellation we are canceling the writer
of this editorial the New York Times
titled jogging has always excluded black
people not a parody that's the real real
title real editorial was written with a
straight face presumably the piece
written by Natalia Melman
Patrice Ola ties the Ahmad Arbor case to
a general epidemic of discrimination
against black joggers and runners
alleging that somehow black people are
excluded from the activity of jogging
that's what she says so she writes in
part this disparity should come as no
surprise running has been a pastime mark
marketed primarily to white people ever
since the jogging craze was born in the
lily-white Oregon track and field world
of the late 1960s black people have not
only been excluded from the sport one
survey by running USA found under 10
percent of frequent runners identifies
African American they've also been
relentlessly depicted as a threat to
legitimate white white joggers and it
goes on from there and it ends on this
note mister our breeze death and the
ensuing outcry is in some ways the
latest data point in the Sikh Mash
of structural racism gun violence and
vigilantism that becomes a hallmark of
American life but it's also an example
of the glaring whiteness of recreational
running a hobby that 47 million
Americans embrace in part because of its
enticing illusion of universalism but
that has never been and still is far
from an equal opportunity endeavor so
she just put a ball if she got it all in
there structural racism gun violence I'm
surprised she didn't I'd climate change
into it I'm sure somebody has done that
by now tied the Armory case to climate
change I guarantee you someone's done it
if I looked it up I could find it but I
won't because I have enough things to be
annoyed about right now okay I don't
think I need to spend a lot of time
addressing this first of all jogging or
running one of the great things about it
is that it can't exclude anybody so if
if one in ten of joggers are black what
does that tell us it just tells us that
black people generally don't like to jog
I mean that's that's what that stat
tells us because if they wanted a jog
they could I mean literally nothing can
stop them unless you don't have legs so
as long as you have legs you can jog in
fact even if you don't have legs there
are people that figure out workarounds
there so basically you can jog almost no
matter what so I'm not sure if white
people got together and decided they
wanted to exclude black people from
jogging I'm not sure how they would even
conceivably do it if that was an in a
project they wanted to take on second
point and this is the obvious one well
this is all obvious but black track
athletes not only do black people run
but they dominates all of the running
events everywhere they dominate the
Olympics they dominate the track and
field circuit in America I ran track as
a when I was in high school I was bi
know it was by no means a white sport I
can tell you that right now it was a
pretty healthy mix of white and black
and other races as well black people
certainly were not underrepresented in
the sport of running in my experience
third point well there is no third point
this is just
I don't even have the energy to talk
about it I mean give me a break just
give me a break with this stupidity
you're cancelled Natalia Melman Petrella
you are canceled you are excluded from
ever writing anything again though you
can still jog I'll give you that because
like I said nobody could possibly stop
you if you want to the only thing
stopping people from going for a jog is
that most not just black people most
people in general don't like to jog it's
it's it's a most people when they think
about what's a fun thing to do I got it
I got 30 minutes to kill what I want to
do at the time most people aren't saying
let me go run that's like the last thing
anybody wants to do for most people
now I actually enjoy running myself but
I realize I'm kind of a weirdo it's a
weird thing you've got you got some time
to kill there are so many fun things you
could do who says to themselves let me
go put on some shoes and go run down the
street only a freak would like me
most people say let me lounge on the
couch okay let me grab a beer I mean
that's a much more normal thing to do
and probably in the long run better for
your knees
we're gonna go to emails in a second but
first I want to take a moment to tell
you about deli wires newest most
exclusive membership tier all access the
all access membership tier is our
premier level of membership all access
members get to participate in all access
live our brand-new interactive
programming feature one of us daily wire
hosts we hang out with you each night at
8 p.m. Andrew Clavin will be hosting
tonight so get excited for that all
access members also get to join us for
live exclusive online Q&A s daily wires
new discussion feature available on both
the website and the daily wire app they
also get the benefits of our other
membership tiers including the add free
website experience access to our all
live broadcasts the whole show library
get all of that stuff so head on over to
daily wire comm / subscribe to join
daily wires all-access Club with a new
membership or an upgrade and get 10% off
with coupon code Walsh that's deli wire
subside subscribe coupon code Walsh see
you there ok so I want to get to a few
of these emails I've been kind of lacks
on reading emails recently
see this is from Ben says hi Matt and
you if you become a daily Y remember you
also get to send messages to this show
through the mailbag so that's that's the
best perk of all you don't have to be an
all-access member of that you just be a
regular member from Ben says hi Matt
what is your take on the mask issue some
people are saying they'll refuse to wear
them others are saying that it's our
responsibility to wear them do you think
wearing a mask is caving in to tyranny
where do you stand on this yeah Ben you
know I'm not dogmatic on the mask thing
I'm just not I don't really have I guess
I don't have an official mask stance as
far as this goes I wear a mask whenever
I go to the store around here because I
don't have a choice because every single
store in my area requires it so I don't
so I wear one and the first thing I'll
say about that is I'm I have always been
a big believer in and defender of the
rights of private businesses to make
their own rules and to set the terms for
engagement no shirt no no shirt no shoes
you know if that's their rule so that's
it you don't have to agree with it if
you don't agree with it you don't have
to go and so if private businesses want
to have a rule saying you have to have a
mask to come in I respect that and let
me what else am I gonna do am I gonna
charge in there without a mask I refuse
and then I'll just get carried out by
security nothing is accomplished by that
whatsoever they have every right to make
the rules I don't have a right to go
into you know Safeway without a mask on
that's not a right that I have I have a
right to go and buy stuff from Safeway
if I follow the rules that Safeway or
whatever other grocery store sets up and
so I respect that now you could point
out that many stores are requiring masks
because they're forced to require them
by the government I'm not a fan of that
I would like to get to a point where and
I would like for that point to be right
now in fact I would like for that point
to have arrived a long time ago where
people just make their own decisions and
businesses make their own decisions
about how they're gonna handle this most
people choose to be responsible anyway
let businesses decide if they want to
require masks or not the thing is many
businesses we
would require it and will require it I
think whether the government says so or
not but as it stands right now even
though businesses are forced to require
the fact is they still require the
businesses do and so I'll wear one
because the other option would be like I
said to charge in their maskless and
just so I can get carried out by
security to make a point I'm not sure
exactly what the point would be or to
not go to any stores but I want to go to
the store and I need to and also that's
part of my whole point I don't want to
be locked in my house I want to get out
and so if this is part of what I need to
do I will do it I just want to get out
and I've go on if I want to go to the
freaking store I'm gonna go and I've
been doing that this whole time so you
know that's that's basically how I feel
about the masks I I think that I don't
wear one unless I'm forced to I've
already said about masks to where the
guys see people driving down the street
and masks wearing them in the car I
think that's stupid
it's kind of crazy if you want to do it
it's your right go ahead okay fine I
think walking down the street in a mask
is crazy and if the government tries to
require that and maybe in some places
they are requiring it that is also crazy
not only crazy but you know I see people
jogging in masks not only is that
unnecessary completely unnecessary but I
I have to imagine it's pretty unhealthy
because it restricts the flow of oxygen
you know you're breathing heavily you're
you're you're breathing in a lot of your
own fumes as you're running down and as
it gets hotter now and it's humid I mean
think about all the germs and everything
you've got your own sweat and saliva and
breath just piling up in this mask while
you're jogging down the street and 85
degree temperature that does not seem at
all good for you
that seems much less sanitary much worse
for your lungs than not wearing the mask
at all so I would recommend that people
not do that but in terms of wearing it
at the store for me it just comes down
to does the store require it or not if
they do that's their right I'll respect
it and I also think that you know here's
the other thing I want to get the
economy going again I want businesses to
open up again I want people who start
getting hired I want all these things to
happen well a lot of businesses
regardless of what the government says I
think a lot of businesses are gonna
require the masks because they're
worried about liability and and you know
we just know what's gonna happen like
eventually things are gonna open up
somebody's gonna get sick and they're
gonna trace that sickness back to
Walmart or somewhere and they're gonna
try to sue Walmart for 50 million
dollars or whatever it is that's gonna
happen and so it shouldn't happen I mean
that's the idea that you could sue a
company because you got a virus while
you were there is dumb but it will
happen in our litigious society so
businesses are gonna want to take
measures to protect themselves against
liability so they can say yeah well we
did what we could
and if businesses have to do that in
order to open up in order to protect
themselves from being bankrupted by
lawsuits then I respect that too all
right let's go to Joe says Matt I
appreciated your analysis of the
Takashi's 6:9 Instagram video I also
love your music reviews in general I'm
sure you know this since he's your
favorite artist but the koshy has a new
song out his first song since getting
out of prison it's called Guba i would
love to see slash listen to your review
of this masterpiece
well thanks Joe and although I am a huge
fan of the musical artist Takashi 6:9 I
have I had not yet had the pleasure of
encountering the Guba song that you're
referring to I did go and search the
video on YouTube at your behest thinking
that I would offer my review of it but
you forgot to mention that I would be
fired if I played even five seconds of
that video on this show so I'm not going
to do that way too explicit for a family
show I couldn't possibly get away with
it but I am always up for offering my
musical reviews of videos and things so
if you have any suggestions that are you
know pg-13 or better please send them
along to the show let's see here there
was one other a couple others a few
minutes I this is from Sarah says Matt
listen to your podcasts about the court
case in
I wondered if it would be better to
forget the battle about the meaning of
women of women and a girl and forfeit
the terminology and focus only on
chromosomes should the girls and their
lawyers argue that there should be
sports for people with XX chromosomes
because vo is born with y chromosomes
have an advantage in sports and should
play on their own I guess you would also
need to clarify that people with two XX
chromosomes who supplement hormones
known to increase athletic ability
should also be excluded from
participating in that category I am just
wondering if those if using those
definitions might make it less emotional
less controversial because the
definition of gender is already too
muddled in our current culture I don't
know if that is giving up the battle
that needs to be fought or just using
correct scientific terms that everybody
can agree on yes sir I understand what
you're saying I've heard the suggestion
before like okay let's just forget about
this you know forget about boy and girl
bathrooms or ladies and and and men and
just put X X and X Y and that sort of
thing and that's kind of what you're
talking about I'm not in favor of that
for two reasons first of all it wouldn't
make a difference it's not gonna work
you're not gonna when it comes to
leftist and they're engaged in this war
against reality and common sense and
science you're not gonna be able to do
an end run around them and and say okay
we'll just call it X X and X Y not gonna
happen
it won't work they won't agree to it so
that's the first thing second thing is
no no I I just I refuse to do it because
you talk about will lettin you know
let's use scientific terms everybody can
agree on the word female is a scientific
term that every rational insane person
can agree on and I refuse to abandon it
same for a woman same for girl all of
these terms we all know what these terms
mean there are a lot of people who
pretend not to know what these terms
mean and then there are a few people who
are crazy and and and maybe really don't
know what what the words mean because if
you don't know what the word female
means I mean there are only a few life
you don't know what the word female
means you're either lying and pretending
you don't know or you're crazier you're
very ignorant I mean or you're like a
child and no one's ever you know you're
you're a four-year-old child oh but if
you're an adult you should know
these words mean and I think that
everybody does almost everybody does
it's just that and we talked about the
court case and it was a judge chat igni
up there in Connecticut he's talking
about trans females he knows what the
word female means this is this is a
grown adult okay he's just pretending he
doesn't so I'm not gonna go along with
that and I don't think we should I think
we absolutely stand our ground on this
and say no no way this is what a female
is the word is important the word has
meaning
it is a scientific biological term and
we will not stop using it and we will
not use it incorrectly just to suit
anyone's delusions it's not going to
happen
finally from Antonio says hi Matt
recently I started getting interested in
the topic of NDE near-death experience
have you read the books of tim vaughn
lamelle or Raymond moody have you had
the opportunity to delve into the topic
what is your opinion about these
experiences well I'll tell you I think
we've talked about this on the show
before but I can't remember exactly just
to give my very brief summary of my view
I'm not a big believer in NDEs near
death experiences well I guess I should
say I believe that people have
experiences I'm not saying they're
they're lying about experiences but I
think the experiences are probably
neurological and psychological nature
not spiritual all the stuff about people
floating up to heaven and meeting Jesus
and and and meeting their dead relatives
and and that sort of stuff I'm skeptical
of all of that for a few reasons number
one we should note that and this to me
is there is the clincher really people
of all religions or no religion have
these experiences and their experiences
are always specific to their own beliefs
so a Hindu person is going to have a
very Hindu like near-death experience I
think that should tell us something
doesn't it I think it just tells us it's
something out of your own head second
these experiences can be duplicated by
drugs like you know like hallucinogens
LSD and stuff like that you can you can
create
a version of a near-death experience
through a drug which I think also tells
us that it's psychological and third the
people who've had n DS aren't actually
dead you know I know they might say
something like I died for three minutes
on the operating table but they didn't
really they didn't actually die they
didn't have a their their brain activity
did not cease they weren't fully dead
now if somebody it's what we call it a
near-death experience now if somebody
actually dies and is buried and a week
later rises from the grave and starts
talking about the afterlife
okay I'm gonna pay attention to that but
that's not this this is near-death and
besides what is the claim is it that
like when you get close to death your
soul sort of accidentally slips out of
your body and floats up to heaven I just
think that metaphysically it doesn't
make a lot of sense so the fourth thing
is and this is important nobody has ever
come back from the afterlife from one of
these NDEs I mean at least when we talk
about documented and modern cases
nobody's ever as far as I'm aware come
back from the afterlife with anything
very special to say as far as I could
tell mostly they just report the same
kind of experiences that other people do
which again is a version of the
experience that a Muslim would have or a
Hindu or anybody else which which also
again often sounds like an LSD trip and
sometimes they come back with a message
from the great beyond I mean people have
written entire books about messages they
got when they went to heaven after they
supposedly died on the operating table
or whatever but the message is you know
not to be rude about it but the message
is never very impressive it's always
just something that I could have told
you without without having to die to get
the message it's never something that
you would think a person would need to
die and go to heaven
to hear and report back so if somebody
ever has an NDE and they come back and
they have a message that they couldn't
possibly have known you know or they
have a prophecy that comes true or like
something like that then I think okay my
ears are going to perk up I'm gonna pay
attention but if they come back and all
they have to say is you know basically
love each other and live your life to
the fullest and stuff like that I don't
know I just don't think that God needs
to pull any any soul from their body to
bring out
having to tell them that and then send
the back I mean they could have gotten
that from a greeting card at home I from
the you know the greeting card aisle at
Rite Aid so that's why I'm skeptical of
all of that but you know I'm as with
anything else I'm open to new evidence
so I do find it how'd you find it
interesting so thanks for that email
thanks everybody for watching and
listening I have a great day
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 science and data are dead and
we have killed them what was holiest and
mightiest of all secular modernity has
bled to death under our knives who will
wipe the blood off us the unelected fake
doctor dictator who now apparently runs
LA County has extended the lockdown
order by three months even as cases and
deaths in Southern California remain low
all in the name of science and data then
a drag queen raises six figures for
abortionists on middle America's
favorite game show something is clearly
going wrong in the culture and the woman
campaigning for vice president finally
endorses the guy she's asking to pick
her all that more check it out on the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]